so I'm not trying to sort of jump and I
thought I ain't gonna even gonna get out
of the way quick enough what I'm gonna
do and these guys is coming down to go
right there
in slow motion it's going
I'm thinking I was gonna get me in the
forehead oh no all right then he's going
down and I'm thinking oh he's gonna get
me I'm gonna get done in here and then
he's going oh no I'm gonna get it I'm
gonna be getting the [__] enough
we'll jump over the car though look I
don't know why yeah jump so I tried to
jump and then as I want to jump up here
got me in the leg
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from
that Bible I'm Ben pal Jones and in the
studio today we've got the larger than
life Dave Courtney thanks so much for
being here Dave my pleasure sir Julie
for anyone who isn't aware of who you
are could you give us a brief
introduction
nope no I'm not going to tell you
I am Dave Courtney I'll come from South
London
um I was propelled into um
intimacy but I really
a documentary was done early on in the
late 70s I think or the early 80s called
burmaji boy
which portrayed me as a a debt collector
car repossession rent a clump get
squatters out you know an all-round for
higher Thug
um
I was on the way to prison and it was a
documentary done to
uh they got permission from the animal
fish to fill me in prison
and they've done it to see if prison
worked I was actually I was on Bell I
was definitely going to prison and they
had they was going to follow me while I
was in prison
um what happened when I come out with my
friends and family stayed low or whether
prison had worked and the job at the
time I was doing was I was a dormer and
I had a lot of drama working for me so
they wanted to see what happened when
the gang boss went to prison and if
everyone stayed low and that was the the
um format of the documentary when I
actually
happily for me got found not guilty and
before they done the court case they
feel me doing all these deathly Deeds to
show how bad I was before I went in and
then when I came out to see uh if prison
had worked well I got not guilty and
that was the end of the documentary said
I had to make a documentary just to have
really horrible things I've done in the
beginning and that propelled me into um
into the Naughty Boy world of stardom so
I'm infomercial being
a little bit of everything okay A little
bit of everything a great way to
describe it and uh I'm excited to hear
what that means so why don't we go back
to the beginning you know what what were
you like as a kid what was growing up
like um oh it's about that big okay pick
my nose yeah weird on the seat
I was the same as any other kid I'm I'm
genuinely walking talking living proof
that you can't blame the parents I lived
in a nice area a nice house I had a
perfect mum and dad they have a cup and
Scout leaders you know I I had no reason
whatsoever to turn out the way I did
it's in your jeans yeah you are born
naughty make no mistake with that
you cannot put it down to a there was no
green area to play on my mum and dad I
was a one pair of fan you know they
might have a little
nudging influences to help you go a
certain way but you are born
naughty I'm afraid I'm proof of that did
you have siblings brothers or sisters I
don't one brother one sister now and
once again living proofs and I'll watch
the odd one out you know I'm quite
I'm quite close to my family you know
I'm quite close to my my mum who's still
alive at 90 odd love you Mum I love you
Mum yeah I'm quite very close my mum and
my sister I've got a strange brother at
the moment
um
but you were the one you would it be
fair to call you a black sheep oh yeah
yeah it's a horrible word for a nice
thing I was quite happy being the black
sheep you know I enjoyed life my main
my main ambition from the minute I open
my eyes in the morning till when I shut
my eyes is too small and giggle and
laugh and have everyone around me under
my little umbrella on the same bus as me
and I'm afraid it was really naughtiness
I was looking at you know money making
pizza and look at his crime I didn't
look at myself as a
as a professional criminal from the age
of 10. you know I mean I didn't look at
it but in reality
I was I most probably um
had ADHD
yeah and um
you know once you've been to prison and
seen all the people at the different
categories of people that are in prison
most of them people at ADHD or um
what like um ADHD or and autistic all
right thank you thank you
well your brain's still working even
though you're looking at him that's good
though he's pretty good um
so um I've been to prison and I've seen
all the different categories of prisoner
there and no one actually understood
autism or ADHD using these years ago
isn't something that's just been
invented it's always been there and
there's an awful lot of prisoners that
the authorities would call rear fenders
they've actually just got ADHD or Autism
yeah and then they they are conditions
that you have to
you have to get under control by a
certain age right now everyone is in the
world you have to get hold of that by a
certain age because up to that certain
age 18 is classed as an illness and bad
behavior and after your 18th birthday
it's prisonable so you've got to start
mending it before then because after
that you're going to go in prison every
time you have a little attack of autism
or ADHD you're going to prison for it
you know you don't get told off sent
into another class give another tablet
right you're banged up and there is all
the prisons are full of all these people
with something that no one actually knew
existed so they put it under the label
of
you know
um
I'll be offended yeah okay I'm actually
I'm actually uh a patron of an autistic
charity aim and our daughter speaks for
speaking for ADHD so I'm a firm believer
in that age half of the criminal element
and I truly believe I ate it myself and
when when you say that you were you were
naughty you were born naughty what did
naughtiness look like at a young age not
English look like anything that was
going to put a pound note in my pocket
really without hurting anyone and
whatever it was that made everybody
laugh and turned me into Center of
Attraction and because of my
I hate to say this about looking like a
cocky butt yeah but there is such a
thing as natural leader material there
is and natural soldiers and each one is
is the same importance to each other an
actual leader need a good soldier and a
good soldier needs a good and I had that
and I had that among men I didn't mind
the back stuff in here I'm not sure of a
few words when I need to get myself into
or out of trouble yeah I can mend an
awful lot more things with my tongue
than I can with that you know and have
done for many years for bigger and
better people than me so it propelled me
into a a position of importance being
very good with my mouth really
so let's look at the the
process of growing up like because
because by the time the documentary was
made that you mentioned earlier I was
very well set in my way right and how
old were you then when they made that
documentary 23 23. okay okay I've
already been a prison once for a
champion murder I went to prison for
three years at 21. okay so that by the
point that's made you said that you you
know in that you're seen you know rent a
clump as you put it which I mean I
assuming example
yeah get a good idea yeah debt
collections car repossession
throwing squat is out so what's the
what's the how does that work like how
do you go from a 10 year old who's you
know Nick in the odd quid here and there
and making people laugh and that sort of
thing what's your progression into all
those things that you've just described
um
I can't really put my put Finger on one
thing but my choice as most people do in
my position now you'll you'll find
a familiarity with their choice of
company was an awful lot older than them
right yeah my choice of
companions were an awful loudness and
the reason I put up with a silly little
one like me is that was funny I'd do it
I'll get in I'll go or you know I know
it's good company so
yeah
I I I was gifted at making people laugh
I feel and I was also gifted when I was
a young man that being able to hold my
hands up I was pretty good having a
fight which
falsely made me think I'd be a good
boxer but I found out very quickly that
oh I wasn't really did I hear you I
don't want to talk about it okay I don't
want to talk about it we'll flip over
that apartment
but
I think I heard you talk before about
um yeah did you get in the ring with him
at a very young age is that correct what
you can delete this in if you want what
you are me why you tosser
and I will now have to bring this
and when you were younger the most
already would have flitted round but I
will have to bring your story out I was
training to be boxing it that's like
yours
it's a good story yeah of course good
anyway thank you I I was actually
training at the time boxing where I got
all of my most of my dormant from
and I was training on Sunday morning up
at the Thompson Beckett nail came around
and Lenny McLean you know oh hell the
best
walking talking nightclub door fighter I
have ever seen in my life uh that you
could never replicate and it could never
be you know but one like that what came
into the ring an inspiring partner
didn't turn up when he was training
he's a giant of a man China man you know
I had the best kit
laughs
are bad and he would responding spot
with me then
and no one said anything and I thought
wow
it can't really hurt me hurt me because
it's only sparring yeah that was my
mental thinking yeah a little bit wrong
um and I could do three rounds with
Lenny McLean I'll hold that close to my
heart for the rest of my life you know I
mean I've got in the ring we've learned
even if he hit me I'm glad he hit me on
for I'll put magic mark around the bot
you know what I mean it was It was a
a hard man with such a fearsome
reputation
the whole country knew of yeah which
there isn't anyone else in like that
anymore there isn't any dormant in
England that everyone in England knows
and is in fear of their set there isn't
anyone you know the times of time
how old were you at this point
um nine
I'll show you something about I did
believe you I suppose
24 or something okay you know it's still
a baby yeah no I didn't have side bones
yet I mean yeah it was a proper man
sideburns the fool
so
you know foreign
because it's powering
individual people skipping and round
around the boxing ring and he's got me
looking pretty casual
and um
you know there's different styles of
fire and like there's different styles
of football like the long ball game or
the Germany you know there's a
Nigel Ben that didn't mind getting it as
long as he got his one in there's a
Eubanks that want to do it here but
didn't actually want to get it yourself
it's the Bruce leader spin around to
bury his ankle when you're here old as a
McManus is a raffle you up you know the
footballer they're gonna rip his shirt
off and dive into 500 blows
you know there's all different ones in
there let me explain
Manny McLean with ding ding and just
before we both moved this is the God's
honest truth he just went
and had to take if I had any [__] in me
it would have been on a good night move
I just instantly big bubbles of sweat
coming instantly my head was down to my
legs run run gag my legs were gone
I just stood there looking at this thing
and it didn't run across the window he
just walked with big steps like like a
monster
and swung his arm around
hey man no I just couldn't get my head
around it making all these noises and
spitting the veins that's his twin like
that make him go down this out of the
good and he just swung this big and and
at the end the end punched me in the
mouth and I woke up with [__] Spanish
sauce
so I did last I did
thank you for making me finish up I did
actually last 17 seconds
okay ten of them was going one
and I thought I'm Gonna Knock this box
uh I'm retired from the fight game fair
enough well you know you got in a ring
with Lenny McLean it's still an Accolade
yeah not many people would say that and
uh no I didn't intend to say that either
how did that because how because he was
famous for being a dormant right yeah uh
how were you a dormant at that point I
was a Dominator at that time normal
American Blue didn't think anyhow now
please believe me
Dorman was someone there if he lost a
fight that night the governor sacked him
and got a better fighter right all right
nowadays you know um if you hit somebody
back you're actually sex they've got
your name addressed blood group
photograph and the government has to
bring you to the police station in your
set and you've got 25 doorman working
one Club when I worked the Hippodrome
there was five dorm and then add 2 000
people in it you had three on the front
one inside upstairs with his thousand
and one downstairs on his own with his
thousands no walkie-talkies going travel
action number five need some assistance
there's none of that you went out man
and done your thing right so was it back
then was the job was a lot of it just
fighting it was all fighting it was all
fighting there was football learning
conservance right 2000 Newcastle come to
London to play Chelsea twenty thousand
man united come to London plus 20 000
Liverpool bloats come down to play
Crystal Palace and only half of them
went home when I said United Square
there's eighty thousand older Orton
openers wanting to have a fight with
some soft Southern boat and there's you
free sitting there were [__] boat's
eyes I'm going oh no I you know for the
whole football so you had to be
in good day and he become very good here
and the reason there will never ever be
another lady McLean the reason there
can't be is fighting you to send this
any other sport in the world right you
can't get good at something unless you
do it a lot right and Lenny McLean had
four or five fights a night five nights
a week for 25 years so by the time me
and you bumped into your mouth pissed on
the way of a club on the way home he'd
eat eight of us
and you can't get goodness I mean if you
hit somebody back now once you get
sacked so are you supposed to be good at
something you're not allowed to do
yeah so you'll never ever I'm sorry it's
all red dominant now not big respects
and all that yeah but you'll never ever
be allowed to be that good
yeah you know they can be that big you
know they want bodybuilding weren't such
a big thing when I was a young man but
there were some big ones around you
understand what I mean so Dave you
started off
um working the doors in your 20s and
you've just explained how back then I
guess before CCTV and and the rules they
have now oh yeah a lot of it was
involved with violence were you not
intimidated by that
um no I'm not that I'm incredibly brave
but people are built different some
people can go mountain climbing and not
get frightened some people can drive 500
mile an hour in a on a motorbike and
Bender they're not front and other
people can have a fight and they're not
friend and once you've had a few items
and realize that you can't get a good
kicking and in two weeks you're back to
normal you know you're not frightened a
bit no more people who haven't who
hasn't done it much
would be fond of it on the very first
time someone jumps out and your
importance a gun at you it's terrifying
but if you're in a world where that
happens quite a lot you know you can
afford up after the eighth time you're
actually going with what you know I mean
I've got some funny stories where
they've pulled out guns at me I've also
got some that are not funny because I've
got [__] animals in my leg but I
forgot what some very funny you know
right no I wasn't um I was intimidated
by the violence it actually
um no I enjoyed the violence it brought
out another part of leadership for me
yeah when everyone else started getting
into the panic mode I turned into Dave
Courtney I always thought it was like I
was almost
sitting here getting filmed yeah
as everyone knows melted if someone came
in the room it helped me grow and so
this is my bed yeah and we not I suspect
this might be a stupid question but did
you have were you not did you feel any
guilt about hurting people or any
worries about hurting people that you
were fighting with no I didn't feel any
guilt with the with the violence of it
because in my heart I had my rubbing
hood on and I never bullied or picked on
or started anything with anyone
ever because I'm the one in charge and I
take that one on board very
seriously you know I could never ever
pop any of my dormant for getting
carried away with their new selves and
being a little bit bullish if I was that
way myself right I sacrificed the
pleasure of being able to walk around
like that because I wanted to tell other
people up for it right I sacrificed me
being on Charlie and having a really
good time but you know you know because
it made you into a dick and I I'll read
a lot of people around me that I looked
at like that but that little packet
there turned them into something no
of sacrifice to be in charge and I took
it on board very very seriously and I've
never felt guilt of whatever I've had to
do yeah I've never felt guilt I have
been in a million positions where
no no I'm lying I've seen in many
positions where they thought they'd done
enough to someone
and as soon as they've got up this
person got up and stabbed them in the
back more of this or jumped up and
carried on doing something so when I met
a fight I've made sure they was
definitely finished I hate the fact that
they have decided to stop hitting me
doesn't necessarily mean I've decided to
stop being them you know so my
reputation means might be that I have
been a little bit
um seriously
um over the top but sometimes yeah but I
would rather you say that about me than
come and visit me in hospital yeah
you know I'm not um I'm not a great fan
of carrying knives so I'm not uh
I believe in you are you must be
prepared to do the prison sentence that
your choice of weapon carries
all right and if you decide to carry a
knife with you
24 hours a day and it turns habitual
which turns into a habit you can offer
it go somewhere and forgot you've got
your knife and then go home to get it
because you just can't do about it
um
and
now I've been something if you haven't
stabbed anybody before please believe me
you know if you're going to start
cheating and use your weapon anyway just
one stab it doesn't stop anyone if
you're going to use a tool you need
somebody to go bum and it all stops a
new win that's what you need yeah and
the knuckle duster I'm afraid it's the
only thing Matt does that
right you won't put a knife and save
your life and put do that to someone
they don't stop they still carry on
running forward it feels like a half
decent punch that's what a knife does so
to stop them you have to do that
all right and then when you go to court
for murder and you'll say it was just
self-defense I didn't want to do nothing
you know say well you stabbed him 13
times as that self-defense it doesn't
stop I'm afraid knuckle duster is the
only thing that stops them instantly and
you don't go to prison for years and
years for it now that right just for any
audio listeners Dave's just produced a
diamond encrusted knuckle duster
wow okay and put it on was the very
first time I had a premature ejaculation
okay sorry about that but it's the truth
it's a more important invention than the
wheel fire and electricity for someone
that's out there having to carry a tool
to work like policemen prison officers
doorman soldiers there was an awful lot
of people out there that do carry
something to work and that stops the
fight instantly you've only got to get
one shot going that way and if it hits
them right they will if they catch him
when the Army will break their arm if we
have Manchester you'll break their ribs
hit them around here they drop on the
floor and I would rather take the risk
of it in 18 months every time I have a
fight than risk it in 25 years and I was
involved in a world where fighting was
something like to do two or three times
a night remember I wanted to or not it
wasn't up to me I'm saying sorry you
look can't come in with it you know
you've got a trainer Zone and it's nine
of you and you've got to come in with
girlfriends you can't come in and
they've decided they're coming in you
had to have a fight on the door all
right then it went into a different
world where the ease and all that came
into it so the doorman was actually
running the drug scene in most clubs
right yeah and and taking over your door
was worth 10 grand a night to some other
little firm so then you had to start
fighting seriously employ more dorm and
that's one in there with a thing all
right so you'd have like rival Dorman
having basically Warzone yeah whoever
was running the door in that club sold
the pills in the club if that club had a
thousand people in it you were said in 2
000 pills in there at 20 pounds each
that's worth kidding someone for that's
thousand Domino and Underpants a night
when you first started
if he was now letting certain dealers in
there settle and then throwing at every
other one so they sold more you know you
could get a little 500 pound bonuses
each every single night or you could be
buying it to type buying them and
putting your own dealers in and earning
thousands of pounds a night and making
sure that the police realized that you
was good Dorman because you were
throwing out every other dealer
so he was looking at you doing your job
correctly so whoever was running that
door then you know if you decided to go
in the smash travel them to him and now
you're the new doorman you was earning
the 10 15 grand a night and the club's
open four nights a week and how do you
how do you become so because I'm am I
right in thinking you were I don't know
what the description is but you run of
like a group of diamonds I run most of
the doorman in London at one stage right
so how do you get to that position like
what did you start as a diamond yourself
started myself and then I started
working for aberdorman so you meet you
know if you're a footballer you know you
have a Footbridge if you're a prostitute
you know how many prostitutes you put a
bodybuilding how many bodybuilders if
you're an Aeronautics you're a
millionaire in addict and I was a
doorman for a long time so
I know a million dormant I'm also
um my my lady was Jamaican
so awful most of my friends were
black guys I understand me and I got
myself London are there more than
natural I've got my own mixed race
children so that was a real
bonus for me that I had another
million odd guys that were prepared to
work for me I see as a little white
London skinhead that they weren't
everyone else right I said yeah I I had
an instant
couple of hundred more on master I look
up a thousand more on my side up and
down the country than everyone else did
that everyone needs someone to be in
charge and being involved in my firm it
made your firm bigger I could now get
him low for a lot of things done up and
down the country by not having a guy
myself and I could get a lot of things
done up and down the country without
them coming down here what I actually
became was a job center
for very naughty men up and down the
country right you might not you know
Dorman
our only Dorman 30 Friday night Sunday
mornings and all that rest of the week
are unemployed they're just sitting in a
gym going
so if you needed anything done you had
the normal layman in the street might
not know where to get someone to bash
out his daughter's boyfriend has to
spread her up throw you next door
neighbor out get a squatter out
repossess a car they might not know that
but you know that Dorman knows a lot
about nuts like that so I became a job
center for a million other naughty man
up and down the country so that is what
propelled me into the importance of what
they now say is celebrity gangster
yeah they brought me to the attention of
Ronnie and Reggie Craig and then wanted
to see me because I had a million gauges
working for me so you started out was it
when at the beginning was it just doll
work or was it always
and petty crime okay so what would the
petty crime have been well Petty crying
would be
bowling everything right you might know
you know there's crimes that most of the
crimes you might plan to do but if
you're that way inclined
you're an opportunist
and your way of handling
situations in your life are a lot
different than the normal person you
know a banker might not do the same to
his next door neighbor to keep having
parties as a doorman
yeah a banker might call the police a
dominant gas motion kind of Kick The
Living Daylights out when we smash his
stereo up my job was debt collecting
which was very easy for me for once
again to put my rubber nude out on yeah
he owed him half a million quid huh and
I didn't care what methods I used to go
in there and get it back he was still
the bad guy I weren't robbing him I
won't just running in there Nick enough
a million quit of him he would actually
say I was the Devil Himself and someone
else when he got his money back and call
me God um were they the amounts he'd be
working with I've been working for
Millions really millions and before
before I became information it was easy
as this you could just kick someone's
front door down and you run in and do
whatever you had to do which then became
illegal by the police to do what you do
to get the money back you know and if
I've knit half a million pound off
someone or gone bankrupt and just
changed name on the top and you know you
would have to go to some lamps to make
me give you back half a million quid
mate you'd have to cut my leg off I'll
get a gold will right if I had half a
million quid but then once a week became
infamous on the Creator in Pro of the
funeral
I did that job truly thinking he was
going to propel me into some working
security icon genius you know I had the
best jobs in world is going to be viewed
and publicized to everyone in the world
and I took it on board that I had to go
and get 150 of the tastiest
men I knew out of my whole filofax
and I'm known as the Yellow Pages of the
underworld that's what it is my head is
full of numbers not crimes you know and
I got Mr Glasgow Mr Edinburgh Mr
Manchester Mr Newcastle Mr Leeds Mr
Liverpool I had affirmed that 150 men
was this for security security for
Ronnie Craig's funeral how did that come
about how are you asked to do it
um well I by the time he died I was a
good friend of both of them okay okay
legs and arms while I was in there for
their last 15 20 years of their life
yeah they got in touch with me and I
went down to see them
for a lot of different reasons I was
going to have a girl that was certainly
an identical twin they were rappers they
made a song called they took the rap
about the cray Twins and it was done by
a set of twins and they led the crater
in March through London and I went down
into sort out contracts for so money out
of this record they wanted to know who
was doing what in London
with this biggest firm that there was
and and I was easily impressed and a
young man
um being associated with the crow Twins
and the Richardsons and
all that was very very beneficial to me
and was it was it it's obviously at the
point you met them they were massively
famous yeah massively famous but I was
in prison but were they intimidating to
me
intimidating to me no their reputation
was fantastic you know if anyone had
ever met them when they was in prison
I'm afraid to intimidating was the last
hold on I want to rewind that okay
Ronnie wasn't being timidane
because she was mad the thing that
really really affected me everybody
weren't the things he said and all that
which was quite unique as well is he
never ever blinked
wow because he'd had 30 years in prison
and for the first 20 years of his prison
they left the light on all the time in
his cell with fluorescent lights when
they first come out they weren't as
eyeball friendly as they are now so he
did fluorescent lights on so he would
talk to you constantly like that hello
David
have you bought something for me to eat
would you go to the canteen and buy me
some things God it's nice to see you
you know he never ever blinked and that
used to make you go you know
I mean well a lot of people say you know
Ronnie was mad and you know when you
look back at that what what do you think
that was like do you think he actually
had something yeah it was something
definitely wrong with him yeah he was he
was abandon if I had clarified stamped
paranoid schizophrenic right and he was
in charge of the firm so it was only
ever going [__] Daniel I mean it was
um Rennie was Reggie was more of a
businessman the more
um
happy go lucky
friendly fella you know I mean you know
um
their their sexuality has got nothing to
do with it whatsoever some of the
tastiest most violent scary men I know
are actually gay but they were both full
on gay
uh from right from the start
um
Ronnie would get yeah if anyone said
nothing you know was more open with it
and I ended up shooting someone in the
head because he called him gay Reggie
didn't tell anyone about it and um
married somebody and didn't fail for a
year so she killed herself yes I mean
and uh
now I'm not making these things up I
don't come on this program and say
things that were wrong or I'd end up and
holding me I'm telling you how it was
yeah
but um
I ran their little bit of East London
when it was
when it you know and run it with an Iron
Fist and done it really well and and
went for the glamor as I did yeah it got
very very famous but it was an awful lot
of other naughtier firms in London than
the cray twins I'm afraid you know
Freddie foreman and the Richardsons on
this side of the war on the other side
of the war yeah there was the nashes
over here in in
you know there was an awful lot of other
families that were just as
notorious or as as naughty as them but
didn't do the I don't really want to be
on the Telly they can wait to get in the
newspapers I mean they couldn't and was
it when you're saying there was lots of
these firms all over the place in London
would they what was the relationships
like were they warring or were they
Sometimes good sometimes volatile I mean
they just come out of a war there was
beautiful criminal morals among the
British criminal fraternity it was
almost romantic then you know we've just
come out of a war everyone went loose
lips sink ships walls of ears one spy is
more dangerous than ten thousand men so
if there was a policeman at the time
trying to get somebody to cross somebody
up was hard work because the whole world
had grown up with them
morals you know I mean you could leave
your front door with a key hanging on a
bit of string through the letterbox you
know if you would have said to someone
then
um there's going to be a program on
telly in 25 years time where they're
going just for grasses to say and if you
see this man just ring us up and we will
put his face on telly and we'll send you
some money oh and if you see this man as
well you know they say oh we've had two
phone calls if you told me there'll be a
program like that and a grass line for
um anyone know anyone you know who can't
tax it or anyone's working and not were
claiming that anyone's got gun in their
ass wanna sells drugs every time you're
at the newspaper there's a glass line
for somebody else what were the kind of
clubs that you and your firm I don't
know yeah all the big UK ones all the
big UK one yeah Ministry no I've done
all this so did an awful lot of other
other
end but my doorman which ended up a
fenced amount to people and they ended
up working everywhere every main club in
in definitely London and up and down
Great Britain all the festivals all the
football you know as soon as the ease
came in a club that normally would have
six dorm and add 26 right and what what
like just going into some of the details
of it you know like what were some of
the more dangerous clubs and what were
some of the what what were some of the
most dangerous things that could
possibly happen like is it is a fight as
far as it went or were the possible
shootings on evenings
there was two there was two sides to it
there was um
there was the one that was on show in
the nightclub itself the little show for
awesome you know whatever is happening
on that and a lot of people were a
little drive-by I suppose it's the worst
you would actually get and then there
was a clever people that mended it out
of 12 hours right no no no owner wanted
the nightclub fights and deaths and
stabbings and even if the diamond won
the confrontation the police knew about
it they didn't need that so it'd be
better to find out who's who mem was
silly enough to actually go out
fermented and bring out everyone they
actually had on their firm so you knew
all they all were you had all the
registration numbers of their cars and
if you were a clever you would go around
to men there in their house at seven in
the morning oh so when you say nothing
right okay headboard what a lion there
in bed with three of you in a battle
Club but that normally changes the game
right yeah listen all right listen shut
up love shut up I'm talking to you about
you sitting in the gear with sharp I'm
talking to you about selling the gear
yeah listen to me right that's normally
a game changer well instead of running
past someone's nightclub and taking a
shot at the window and driving off right
please and if you when you say taking a
shot there were guns prevalent guns were
yeah yeah they
you're you're actually fighting for the
for the domination of the drug selling
in their club which might end up being
sometimes 50 to 100 Grand a week so I'm
afraid to the fighting you actually do
is no longer knuckle dusters and
if you have 10 doorman instead of five
or yeah you're fighting for thousands
and thousands and thousands of pounds
I'm afraid up goes the level of violence
and that is a part of that's all your
trade where I used to be I'd have a
knuckle duster on me or now I have to
employ someone to walk around and carry
it out and I don't have you so you see
you never carried guns
you know
you know I'm the boy I'm in charge I
don't have to he does well got you okay
interested were there any case were
there any times where you thought
you were in a million times I've got
house in me mate you see so I've got
algae Mike can you tell us about that
what happened yeah yeah yeah I was um I
hate this I was standing outside a
nightclub the kids are pulled up in the
driveway it's shooting someone's very
hard you think it's quite easy you've
only got like me and you'll get it more
that's it a whole person you think I'm
gonna miss that from 24 but you do
you do especially if they're running a
movement about you know
and someone went Dave
Courtney in the yellow escort Mexico
with a black vinyl roof and I was too
far away to get
but I went yeah
I know
I don't I walked right up to the window
of the kids and it was gonna shoot me oh
wow that's exactly what I thought
yeah so you just called you over yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and and that's
always so as I let in as I was bending
down to see space I see him pulled a gun
up and it went anything like
life-threatening comes into play for
some reason
everything goes into slow motion so I'm
going to explain something to you now
it's going to take me about five minutes
which happened as quick as this as soon
as I looked and wondering and I was
close enough he went
shot me in the leg I said who he was
in my head as I come to winter start
bend down to have a look I saw it and he
was bringing it up and I thought oh
no so I'm not trying to sort of jump and
I thought I ain't gonna even gonna get
out of the way quick enough what I'm
going to do and there's Casey's coming
down to go right there
and slow motion is going
I'm thinking I was going to get me in
the forehead oh no all right then he's
going down in the yard and I'm thinking
oh he's gonna get me I'm gonna get down
there now and then he's going oh no I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna be getting enough
we'll jump over the car Dave block I
don't know why yeah jump so try to jump
and then as I went to jump up here got
me in the leg and what it felt like
nothing I can tell you where you go I'm
only slowing you down man you're going
with that he's nothing like that
it felt like
and when
on my ankle does he hit my ankle when
you turn my ankle right up in here
upside down and I came down and landed
on my face
huh
and I was unconscious there for a minute
until the ambulance pulled right up
beside my head and they've got their
owns right underneath the actual thing
and right when it pulled up beside me it
went
like that is
wow you know and then what so so he he
intentionally shot you in he wasn't
trying to kill him so what what's why
why was that age because his boss
was
um
gonna have a lot of trouble with some
with my boss
and before he had to go with my boss he
had to get rid of me hmm as I would have
done anything I was told or paid to do
when I was on the up and up yeah see
yeah and if and you know it's all down
to she knows the artist or the toughest
anymore and that's really not it
it's who's got the numbers in the phone
right and that really is what it's all
about not the biggest categic nurse none
of that
oh none of that all right I'm a
dangerous man I don't care this is much
of the cockiest thing I'll say to you I
don't care what bit of trouble I'm in
what country I'm in or where whoever
it's against
if you let me get to my phone
I will [__] you
right
that's true not me no I'm the toughest
not nothing to do with it and there's
people out there with my name in their
phone
all right and if you if you're in
trouble you could bring me and if I
couldn't do it I could drink even if he
can't do it he gets them
I said it's not what you can do that
many and there is what you can get
that's what that was about this man who
was going to get it could get me so
before they got him to make sure I was
out of the game not dead we're gonna
drive by killing you know actually
killing someone the murder Hunt is
horrifying if you've ever been involved
in one it goes on for months they in
interview you your school teacher who
you fill out with in infants your next
don't know who you run three years ago
why did you re except you know I think I
think murder
is the highest rate of
um captures of any other crime in the
world I mean okay something like 97 oh
wow murder right I don't think I'm far
wrong there might be 95 of every murder
there is and everything else is down in
the 18 21 or whatever murder
so people have now learned that you
don't murder that this has come all the
way from Eastern block people what we've
learned from them is you do not leave a
body to be found for murder people just
gone missing persons list all right and
if you would like to go and do your Maps
or get your researchers to have a look
the missing persons list is right up
there
huh murders might be going about for a
little bit more than last month and all
that but on the missing persons list
which don't even make the local paper so
didn't come home last night
and they will find when they're doing
the investigating so many reasons you
shouldn't have come out he was on drugs
he was hanging around with him he had
another bird no one's even looking now
to go and pay someone to get to murder
someone there's a lot of money when I
was younger because you're 15 20g to go
and get someone shot and they left a
body there
all right now because you 7g to go and
have someone took away and never ever
seen again yeah there's a whole
different set of people here doing that
work so that's how you do it there is no
murder on the person who prayed for it
to get done this much will be helping
the wife looking for him oh God
and so when something like that happened
to you that obviously for most people
getting shot would have been like a sort
of life-defining event but like did you
win a free legging no but were you were
you were you angry did you want revenge
off you was like I didn't know what it
was about at first right
Revenge weren't well weren't here I was
just lucky it was there and not anywhere
else you know I know for other people
getting shot at the time so
you know I didn't change my life I'm
going to change my whole life because
that happened you're now in it is your
associate you are there you are now
naughty and if you're in a family of
naughty people but they shot you because
you worked for someone else is there any
sort of like like compensation in that
world like do they go you've been shot
so we're going to give you this money
you are lovely you are okay right
honestly fine worth checking I'm
actually gonna write that down and
put that out there just a little memo is
there any compensation do you know what
I mean though like you've taken a book
for someone else no no no no you could
if you're silly enough to and you've got
enough time and you just want to go and
waste your negative energy on Revenge
and learn running man doing that there's
a million people you could choose for a
million different reasons and if you've
got
2 000 people working for you keeping
myself out of trouble is easy it's easy
let me tell you something now right
now I'm now I'm no longer doing anything
active and all that that no dust okay
with me is purely a prop and all things
like that all right it's keeping myself
at Subway's easy but I've got people
that have worked for me for 30 years
they've got holes in their body down to
me they've been to prison for me all
right so when they knock at my door
tonight and go Dave help me I just cut
my wife shagging the neighbor I've
killed him and I want to get out of the
country help me what do I do
sorry I'm writing books here I'm going
to tell you I don't do that
um
or do I make a phone call and help him
and then I'm back in here
and because the police know that thing
they're on my phone my ass they fill my
ass they're you know
so I'm I'm keeping me out of trouble
it's easy it's everyone else knocking on
my door going to die die and I can't go
because I'm a nice better really no so
they just wait for the time where they
can catch me doing that so they still
listening on my phone were you so you
you mentioned earlier that you were sort
of like brought to sort of national
attention after the craze funeral and
you use the term I I I think I've heard
you say you don't like it so I'm just
saying you use the term celebrity
gangster yeah yeah yeah celebrity
gangsters I thought he was going to
propel my security company yeah into
Mega you know yeah but it actually
brought me to the attention of the
general public yeah Andrew the attention
of all of the authorities and it came
out that that was their very first
visual proof of organized crime in this
country you know one criminal organizing
every other criminal in Great Britain
because everyone I brought down had
their own criminal CV their own little
firms although these firms didn't get on
with each other but on that one said day
where we're burying the actual
Monarch of the underworld yeah Ronnie's
radio gone they all behaved so it was
one criminal organizing every other
criminal in England to come down to one
place be seen not hiding up Allies with
a collar up ground up which is no coming
doing that right for the burial of a
super criminal here is the first sign of
organized crime they'd ever my God huh I
didn't actually work clever enough to be
thinking that I'm thinking right you
know I'll show off here everybody in
England and America will have a look at
what the British crime thing's doing
I'll give him something to look at I'm a
bit like that but not realizing what the
authorities are going to think about and
from that day on it destroyed me right
it actually destroyed Dave Courtney I
could no longer kick someone's door down
and run in and do debt collection or
anything because everyone went it was
Dave Courtney her name saying montelli
yesterday I was just something
disconnected
I'm paying a check before I got to the
counter they went
[Laughter]
yeah you know I couldn't
no longer do nothing so I then became in
the newspapers heir to the throne
celebrity gangster and I didn't actually
want that so I quickly had to think of
something to do that was just as public
that choked me took me off of that
super gangster thing you understand I
mean no no no gangster runs up into the
sunset and lives happily ever after or
um
you know just don't work you end up with
another couple of holes and you didn't
want or 35 years right around you so I
wrote your book quickly and called it
stop the ride I want to get off
yeah which is really it and seeing
everything I then did became newsworthy
whether I wanted to or not they're
writing about me taking pictures of me
and all that super gangster celebrity
gangster I thought right I'll have a sit
down and try and hide down a little
alley in
Essex where Brown Tweed suit and try and
hide from this or as soon as they're
doing loads of press on me anyway
jump up take it take it by the orange
and steer it into whatever way I could
do it on a celebrity thing I'm not there
anymore but blah blah blah which didn't
go down well with some people because
most most naughty men and villains and
criminals were the rule was no pictures
no comment make down an alley color up
Loki car and there's me again
yeah if I was nobody's home I'm doing
that I'm no longer at it so by the time
people knew I was celebrity gangster I
no longer was I'm not telling anyone I
was a gangster I'm saying I knew a lot
yeah am I noddied the right way for
things to happen and that for me
personally I'm not the Best Buy I had
the best shot I've not I've never said
that you know no one can plastic
gangster and all that the best one I
heard of the other day Panda around
gangster they've been always pound pound
I love that
a bendy Dave but you had to put you had
like I mean you became a film star
you're in teams I've done whatever they
asked me to do them once my book become
a number one bestseller which shocked no
one more than my English teacher and
they'd interested to do another book
about the Rave scene
all right my first book stop the ride I
want to get off Facebook I have a ropes
I never thought I was going to write
another one I've just done it to go look
I ain't doing any more
right you know they went to every single
Club I had a doorman and denied it I
mean if you employed Dave Courtney
storeman you were never licensed for a
[__] television mate so second today
right everyone I was doing my walk
around audience web shows they went
there and said I don't want Courtney's
boys meet in your Pub right you're
coming up for your license in four weeks
cancel it right I went to the magazine
where I was an uh crime writer and all
that I said get rid of him why why do
you think they did that well because the
popularity was was what was killing them
you understand what I mean I was running
for Lord mayor once I run for Lord mayor
and underman wow did you I didn't know
that oh look you don't know look yeah um
sorry
yeah I'll run for Luke mail once and
um
you know I'm not saying anyone was going
to vote
um Ken Livingstone and change your mind
about Dave Courtney I think it's only 79
12 the vote for London and at the time I
had a magazine circulation The Front
Magazine where I had thousands of
followers I was putting on Raves I'm
down the country where I was getting
thousands of people to go to Raves and
pay 50 Quid to get in so to go and get
cut them 100 000 people to come down to
a polling station and do that for
absolutely nothing I became Lord mayor
and that frightened them right I
actually fighting them seriously I mean
the Lord mayor's in charge of the
Metropolitan Police
I didn't give him a year off I'd have
made them all wear them noses with the
mustaches I'm in charge yeah you know
they're absolutely terrified him
and um
while all that was going on you know
um I had strangely then got run over by
a mysterious man on the M25 on the A2
in the middle they're not not drunk hit
what I was in a Range Rover no one
and I was pit maneuvered now I don't
know
any other gangster in the world
that has tried to kill any other
gangster in the world doing the pit
maneuver I don't know anymore pit
maneuver I love you
you're beautiful a paper maneuver is a
maneuver that the police use when
they're chasing someone and they ping
them and see stuff okay only the police
do it we don't
you know I can figure a million
different ways to shoot you rather than
wait till you're on the M2 on camera
doing that more an hour and do that
right but that happened to me I ended up
going and I suppose in a coma for seven
months I was in hospital and when I come
out they said all of the film footage of
the A2 wasn't on that night wow because
I couldn't catch it right and luckily
for me they said there was an undercover
it was a off-duty policeman following me
that took down all 13 witness statements
but because I was in a coma if Mr
Courtney doesn't understand office
environment things do get lost and all
the witness statements are lost
so what do you think that was and what
do you think that was what do you think
well I'm actually arrested and I've
nicked the police they've actually
called me a grass I I I went to court
with them with a bent policeman that
I've been paying for years and years for
years and years and I'm afraid every
when when I was a criminal if you did
have a bank couple you're a fool
everyone had one you know what I mean no
one had one and when he went anyone got
caught he didn't say yes I'm working for
Dave for the last 15 years because
they'd be all retailers compensation on
it he said I was working for him which
only been believed would have got me
shot but it did cause me a lot of eye
and a lot of pain and stopped the
popularity thing and they run around for
eight months while the court case was
going on saying Courtney might be a
glass called he might be a grass which
still hurts but it weren't proved I
actually got not guilty this is my sexy
Star as a criminal forgive me if you see
a little lump on my trousers forgive me
I went to the Old Valley and got not
guilty and the Copper got a five
stop it
I got no give when I say one more time
I'll go Nokia in a couple got a five at
my biggest day crime wise you know and
um
after that I then took out a private
summons at a high court of justice with
Bill married a bloke who played the bank
Opera in the bill and um Martin brunt
filmed it for sky and said look well I'm
nicking the police for attempted murder
you called me a grass when you know and
it was proved I wasn't I actually bugged
the copper and added them the tape
right up till the day the court case
started then he went gooey and said no
it was me who said for eight months
while I was instead of being oh Mr
popular during the race during the
parties writing the books running for
Lord mayor now he stopped all day and
went he could be grass could be glass
could be a grass stops all of that got
sat through the doorman and then on that
day that it was proved I wasn't and the
couple went to prison they just didn't
put on the Telly right you know so that
was he made me do something while all
that was going on I was so frustrated
with the fact that
um he was calling me an informant on one
of the court cases that we was going up
to call I had said to him if you put me
in the dock with him I if you put me
within Arms Reach of him I will chin him
and I've got it all on tape so they did
believe it because while we were going
to magistrates they put him on in the
morning in the meal in the afternoon him
in the morning in the afternoon and then
one day because they were going there
might be a glass cut it might be grass
and I could see the popularity thing
hurting me and it was hurting me
I went a coat dressed as a court jester
with all the bells and the things and I
bought 40 of my mates all dressed in
black and I went into court and as I
went into court today and say look it is
a joke I shouldn't be here you know blah
blah blah he was coming out
so I changed him and I knocked him out
in court it was all on all on uh 10
o'clock news oh my god really forget oh
my God stuff just call me Dave
so you're just in front of all the
camera out of everything I've tuned him
yeah the rest of the Japanese
dress is a cool Jester I knocked him out
it's on the 10 o'clock news you can go
and have a look at it and um I'll grab a
little speech afterwards blah blah blah
and and I've done I've done audience
with you know around the world a bit
necessity to talk to the mafia with 25
Mafia men and five interpreters going
this there's a there's an Unwritten rule
book about Guyana cool and everyone in
the world knows you all right it's
Unwritten this one is you do not bring
all your friends you wear a nice suit
and it's yes or no sir and a letter from
someone that's known you 20 years saying
you're a nice bloke they're the rules
are kind of cool for everyone right the
only people that don't do that are
across in Austra because they know it's
jungle what's the point they've been
showing up to turn up and go I'm a nice
bro so they turn up to cool gangster he
said the only one we've ever seen do
that is you tell me what was going in
your head that day and so I've been out
there and done talks for them and I've
now traveled the world explaining why I
did what I did that day but I was so
frustrated at what they were doing to me
you know I mean I knew I was getting
lucky they knew I was getting knocked it
with they had the tape of me
doing him but they allowed all this to
be written the Press just to hurt me and
on the very day the court case started
he went okay guilty
yeah just do it and it did stop me I
never got voted in lucky for Ken Davis
though you know and and
it did slow down a little bit and I did
lose it to him and it did actually hurt
me but I'm sitting at a territown I'm
not moaning about the sad bits about an
awful lot of good [__] well when you
say that you got you got found not
guilty how many times have you actually
been sent to prison in your life
um I'm famous for getting knocked
Killers I've had over 20 knockils wow
and the reason the reason I could get
away with things then before technology
ain't it great
all right and it great is being very
popular and having an awful lot of
friends the first rules in the
Archibald's the law book is if there is
any doubt whatsoever that you might be
knocking away they have to go not
getting
and if a policeman saw you shoot someone
but you could pull up 30 witnesses to
say no we was with Dave he heard a bang
ran over picked up the gun and then the
couple ran over and grabbed him if you
had a policeman a fireman a soldier or
two nurses or if you had 30 Witnesses
saying it weren't you
and prepared to go I swear children
we got all right that's element of Doubt
so you would be found not guilty so
about 20 odd not guilties due to people
helping me now you can't do that because
as soon as you pull up any witness they
check your Facebook
you can't have him he's your best mate
and anyone that's close enough to you
that would lie and cool for you is on
your Facebook
I need right and now you can't do that
no more
and I've had some blinding ones in court
man this and I've had some absolute
peaches in court and my little statement
my little step one of my sorry sorry
shelf here they're gone while I was
actually in that cool case with the
copper the whole the whole Gallery was
packed and as they're sentencing and
they're giving him the five years and
I'm getting not guilty I'm looking at
them not realizing the judges on me and
I'm looking at them trying to emphasize
the
really doing it too much
you go and check all the cool things you
remember Connie
he said that look on your face could be
mistaken as gloating
I said your honor I said it's no mistake
but you so you're famous for not
guilties but am I right in thinking that
you actually met Charles Bronson no no
no I heard Joshua I didn't meet him I
heard him I've been to prison I suppose
if I'm remind
I've done
five and a half years I suppose I'm
reminded I've done a year of my mind got
not guilty eight months got not guilty
six months not guilty six months not
good
um and um
one of the times I was in prison when I
was a good friend now the very first
time I ever heard Charles Bronson I was
in the special unit at belmarsh which is
a prison built within a prison
for the 40 most criminally minded
criminals in Great Britain and it's a
remand thing while they're waiting to
get 50 years 100 years or whatever
and it's for people with the financial
ability to get out on the Manpower you
know and at the time I had found an army
out there
it was two o'clock and this is a very
good impression I know Charlie very well
and I was lying in bed and um
and Dave Cody coming in prisoner just
needs a little baby's Fender I think no
nothing more than that
and I heard
Courtney
ruined away
completely
completely put in awake
oh where was that Courtney
I'm thinking this is the truth I
remember it like yesterday the only
chance I got is there might be someone
in here called cooking
I'm gonna buy an old in your chest and
suck my life ahead of you
[Laughter]
I was
truly petrified and I teach people don't
be fried to someone's voice that'd be
found on the phone anyone can bring it
up don't do that but that dummy is
completely dumb and the whole prison is
chatting to each other at the windows
going princess ducky I'm Bronson stuck
in corner when they're all talking to
each other and you can hear the the
other 1500 Whisperers
I don't know what you're gonna do what
you can turn around
now I don't know at this time
he's in solitary confinement and the
chances of me ever bumping into him I
have more chance of genuinely bumping in
the queen right that's the truth I have
more chance of me bumping into the queen
than I ever would chance to bumping into
Charlie Bronson who's in solution
fireman who's locked up in a hole in a
thing he's never seen anyone for 30
years now I didn't know I weren't going
to bump into him in the library in the
gym down at church I didn't know that
which my ex might might explain my next
move so I didn't know I weren't going to
Batman him
so with that in mind you know they're
all going I'll call yourself come to the
window and win in my best South London
tanks divorce
Charlie
Worley
come on
be yourself in here right I can't
actually say no no because it's 11 1500
people dirty so I can't actually say
anything else I don't know and I was
never going to see him I'd have gone oh
you [__] talking to you oh that'd be
tomorrow I don't know but anyway never
he's become a very very close friend of
mine he actually Rings me every other
day and sings to me now wow you can put
this in your show I've got to put I put
them up on your website he sings
different songs to me all the time every
day
um
and about two of his wedding receptions
in my pubs and all that you know I think
what's happening with Charlie is I'm not
going to send them out
yeah I've written a crime is just you
know he might be a little bit
it might be a little bit uh mental
health at the moment and not enough to
play out on the road but he's definitely
well enough to knit out of solitary
confinement they've kept him in fact
solitary confinement for 30 years
all right
all everyone really should be saying
it's not name out he's take him out
there and say hello to someone then say
good morning to someone and say good
night then stand beside someone I never
weigh in the toilet name sit beside
someone and watch Telly any normal
thing yeah just no matter you know if he
does something wrong again and then look
him up inside but not to keep a man in a
Cupboard not talking to anyone he does
his exercise on his own dinner comes
under you know you don't see anyone to
do any
you know even the hostage that he took
hostage was stood up at the court case
and when I was in Nova physical danger
all he done is kept me there and spoke
to me continually for 24 hours you know
he just wanted to talk and get some
reaction chat and what color ball pipe
we got man he just wasn't even the
hostage these horses went blah blah they
had the screws that look him up when
might be a little bit wrong but someone
at the home office went no keep him in
there right now hear me with this this
is only my own personal reason for that
all right
but cleverly if I was him they are doing
that to one person which is a bit wrong
right morally you know right but by
doing that to that one man they have
kept every other prisoner in England
under manners which if you now want to
start tearing up prison cells Climbing
Up on the Roof lighting fires taking
people off ditch they can go do you want
to do that do you want to do that to you
do you want us to look you up here
forever
yeah because we do okay I know he got
seven years he's done 47. right you want
that and it slows you down if they start
being nice and letting him out they
haven't actually got a deterrent or a
threat um
you understand me personally that's why
I think the only possible reason of an
impure vindictive nastiness and with the
amount of public support he's got at the
moment you know they might be shouting
for too much of a touch you know let him
out all right yeah but like wow
I can't think of any other reason that
they would continually be so
blatantly openly spiteful and not worry
about what the general public think and
go no he's not doing it um
you know educate me if if you would if
someone would like to tell me there is
another reason I'll grab that you know I
can't make sense and like look over this
conversation we've talked about some
like very famous British gangsters you
know Bronson The Craze yourself McLean
those kind of huge names like do you
think those kind of people who get films
made about them books written about them
TV series made about them do you think
they're still being created in the UK or
do you think that was a period in time
now I'm afraid it's appeared into them
yeah what what why well exactly the same
as
famous no women in the past is is a
historical thing like Cowboys Pirates
nice and shining armor gangsters it's
all an old-fashioned thing anyone trying
to be one of them
they're building prison to put you in
yeah not like the individual Lenny
McLean's there ain't no doorman now
that's known up and down that country
there ain't no bank robber that's so
famous everyone in England knows them
there ain't no prize fighters on
everyone's lips there ain't no you
understand I mean yeah it's it's a
romantic thing of the past like I said
you could almost stand up in an era once
afterward and say in school my dad's a
criminal my dad's a villain and be proud
of it now standing up saying my dad's a
drug dealer ain't got the same cut yeah
it ain't the same there's a period in
history it's a period in history where
you know
and I don't know why but they're in
child especially today that we're not
like that no more they're entitled to be
here realized you know or wrote about or
films about they were a different breed
that we are no longer you know like
cavemen Cowboys there's a different era
of men that they don't make no more yeah
the English criminal you know that we've
been running bethnal green was a lot
easier then when there was only 50 000
people in Bethany green and everyone
spoke and understood English for The
Craze
and free quotas of them couldn't say the
name correctly
huh
you know we all had the English
criminals hailed human life at a certain
standard you know the different
nationalities that call this home now
it's not the same you know human life in
Albania Bosnia Moscow
Afghan you know it isn't the same value
so the crimes and the what tools they're
carrying and the values of life and
honor among Thieves is no longer there
no more um
right now honor among drug dealing um
I know I'm not
I'm not saying I'm knocking it most of
my friends are I have been and still do
take you know I'm not
yet the the rewards your financial
rewards are that much now you it's too
tempting not to but I'm afraid with that
much money you're going to get an awful
lot more people dying and getting hurt
and going missing and being disloyal
grassing up and
about it you understand me
okay so I guess my final question for
you Dave is you know when you look back
over your life and and
obviously been a very colorful
interesting one you know what do you
think your life's taught you you know
what's something that you believe that
you've become aware of that other people
might not know through the experiences
you've had
hold your family close
hold your family close and
stay true to you stay true to you don't
be easily impressed
all right
and be a little bit happier with what
you've got instead of clambering for
someone else
because it's a clambering for something
else don't try and impress anybody
that's where bullets come from and try
and impress anybody with I've got to get
the money to get the back up be happy
with the car you got right you are in
the wrong era now to be a g you're in
the wrong area you're not competing
against a Sherlock Holmes policeman no
more
yeah you're trying to be fun technology
and you can't
right you can't judge before being a
good judge a character would keep you
out of prison but now your phone will
grasp you up your Sat Nav will cross you
out the cameras on the traffic lights
you know you are
to find another way than crime to get on
or your your own illusion battle that's
that would be my advice
great it makes complete sense listen
it's been a brilliant conversation
everyone wish I could show you the same
okay yeah final dig appreciate that
everyone's been laughing throughout your
uh
withering takedowns of me but um I'll go
back to host school thank you very much
for coming in Dave it's been a pleasure
yeah me too man me too thanks mate got
in as soon as my eyes adjusted I thought
oh my God that's that's that's that's
um Rodney Christ into the table and
there's Reggie at the bar and Frankie
Fraser's in the corner Ronnie comes out
to me and says hello son he said hello
sir don't call me so don't call me sir
he said uh my boy said you've done the
smudge then I went yes